and we think discipline is a punishment
but actually nobody has a shittier life
than a person who has no self-control No
Boundaries no rules you know who whose
life is chaos it sucks you know the
world has become infatuated with not
being accountable yet one of the increa
incredibly easy straight paths to being
happier and more content and joyous is
to be more accountable Vayner Nation
what is good we are back with the
garyvee audio experience with one of my
favorite guests of the past and I'm just
going to predict it right now one of my
favorite guests of the future I I expect
to have a very long friendship with this
tremendous young man and so I'm excited
to to get right into it because we don't
have too much time on this episode Ryan
holiday is one of the more thoughtful
characters I've come across over the
last 15 20 years of this version of my
career
um and it's been really nice we've
gotten closer in the last five to seven
years after I admired him from afar
um he's rep by Vayner speaker workers
which is a real honor I'm super happy
about it because I was the one pushing
for him to be signed by Vayner speakers
after I had a good talk with him in La
at an event and most importantly I think
he's a very thoughtful author and
voracious reader and a Trevor Trove of a
treasure Trove of information so uh Ryan
how are you
I'm doing good I'm in La you guys just
sent me here on a gig so I'm uh you're
putting me to work I love it so right
tell us about the new book let's just
get right right into it
yeah I'm doing it about something I
think you know is equally important as I
do I'm doing this this series on the
cardinal virtue so I just did a book on
courage and then this new one is about
discipline which I think is a critical
ingredient to success uh I I would I
would be shocked to find someone who is
successful who did not become successful
because of both their personal
discipline and their study of a
discipline deciding to see what they do
as a practice and a crack
so discipline is Destiny is the name of
the book
and and for someone who's hearing that
like oh crap I'm super disciplined or
I'm not disciplined what's uh what's the
opening rant you can give to people to
why this is so significant in success or
Joy or happiness
yeah my point isn't just that discipline
will make you successful like it's a
means to an end discipline is also an
end in and of itself a rewarding one
right so like obviously if you want to
be in good shape you have to be
disciplined about what you need how you
work out Etc
um if you want to be successful in
podcasting or writing or any profession
you have to be disciplined but if you're
if your profession is mowing lawns or uh
sweeping the streets if you are
disciplined about that if you treat it
seriously if you get the edges just
right you care about every facet of it
it makes you great even if nobody else
cares even if nobody else notices so I
want to think about discipline in two
senses it's not just hey
um I'm disciplined because I want to get
to a place in the future where I have
more money more time and and we tell
ourselves I can be less disciplined but
it's actually that discipline in the
moment right now is a sort of guaranteed
form of greatness taking what you do
seriously sweating it working on it
caring about it even if nobody else
notices you know Steve Jobs famously
would talk about how his father told him
that you a carpenter cares about even
the back of the drawer the inside of the
computer that's discipline too and a lot
of it's totally invisible to people you
know it's funny that makes it's funny
where my brain went with that I would
argue that that really lands with me
because
and this might be valuable to the
audience especially the parents who are
raising kids who are finding interests
in new things that parents don't believe
can be professions if anything of the
last 10 years should teach parents it's
a lot of the things that we didn't think
were jobs are or at least things that
make you know parents worry about I want
my kid to make enough money to sustain
their life likelihood the parents of my
generation did not think all those hours
of video games was one of those things
my mom famously told AJ get off the
computer you're on it too much and made
him get a job at amp Supermarket because
she didn't think us playing on selling
on eBay or like what he was doing was
going to be a thing these are
really interesting what when you said
that I would argue that's what
entrepreneurship was for me
I you know when I was selling lemonade
and shoveling snow and even when I was
selling baseball cards I remember making
like 300 bucks at a card show seemed
like a trillion dollars
and I remember teachers and my friends
parents not my parents which is why what
happened happened kind of scoffing at it
or like thinking that the D I got in
science which is was a much bigger
indicator than what I did with the
baseball card show but what's funny is
I've always talked about it as I knew I
knew but I would argue what sprung to me
when you were talking was I just enjoyed
being an Entre it's how I am today
I yeah I get way more joy in the process
of what I do than the fact that I'm
garyvee or the financial ramifications
of what I do came along with it
yeah look there's a difference between
writing and Publishing in my line of
work I love writing I sometimes publish
right publishing is when it goes out in
the world when it makes money when it's
released and all that and that's
important but writing is what I wake up
early to do because I love doing it and
I think your point about you know
anything can be a discipline anything
can be a craft is really important my
son likes to watch these videos by this
kid becro Jack on YouTube who does
Minecraft videos yep and I and you know
I I don't love it I don't it doesn't
make any sense to me why you would want
to watch someone play play YouTube but I
was trying to to tell my son that this
person is also an entrepreneur also an
artist and that's why he has an on an
audience of millions of people in that
you can enjoy it but you should also
respect the fact that he got really he
got so good at something that he's one
of the few people in the world that
makes a living doing that thing and
that's what we should take away whatever
it is that you love if you like throwing
darts be the best Dart thrower in the
world to me it's why even in the 80s
growing up when I felt that stay-at-home
moms were disrespected way more by the
way for all the youngsters who are
socially like thoughtful
um it was way worse in the 80s and I
remember being very affected by that
because I actually really knew while it
was happening that my mom was
orchestrating a masterpiece
I I like literally vividly remember
being 12 13 that range 12 13 14 and
saying my mom's smarter my mom's doing
it better and and I think please
oh I was gonna say I think about this I
remember you know I would take my our
two kids to this daycare and I think
about these these three women that put
24 year olds down to bed at the same
time for nap in the middle of the day
and you think about the energy and the
skill and the craft of even that so that
think of the emotional discipline the
patience the calmness that you have to
radiate outwards to do something Ryan
wouldn't what what couldn't the argument
in this Checkers chess game of this
conversation play out with a Checkmate
that says discipline could be a gateway
to all eight billion people's happiness
yeah I mean I I don't think here's the
funny thing we think that discipline
sucks right like not getting to eat
everything you want not getting to do
everything you want not getting to spend
well we we we think discipline sucks in
the things that don't come natural to us
you know to me you know what I mean I'm
saying is yeah we think discipline is a
punishment but actually nobody has a
shittier life than a person who has no
self-control No Boundaries no rules you
know it's it's the way life is chaos
it's the way it's the way I think about
accountability on P you know the world
has become infatuated with not being
accountable yet one of the increa
incredibly easy straight paths to being
happier and more content and joyous is
to be more accountable
yes so tell us please
go ahead sorry sorry I really want to
get into the book a little bit because I
I feel like a lot of my audience is
going to buy it or is considering it
because they've they have a sense of you
and things of that nature so I guess
you know who's this for or or how do you
write it in a way that brings value to
someone who views themselves as already
disciplined or if someone's listening
and saying [ __ ] I'm really not
disciplined like how did you structure
it in a way to give somebody maybe a
spark to start the process or is there
you know how do you think about that
well I I obviously like you identify
with the first category I'm a very
disciplined person I've always been
disciplined that's been the root of a
lot of My Success but you and I
own battles
um overwork burnout over committing uh
you know not uh uh can I can I say
something right can I say something like
no [ __ ] this is really actually just
a moment to jump in
actually I'm probably saying this
because I'm asking you because I do find
you very thoughtful
I
I am very overrated and misunderstood on
the like I've never felt professional
burnout in my entire life I'm not joking
I
this is why discipline is interesting to
me I'm trying to like put these puzzles
of all these emotions together
I I the best way I've articulated it the
place I've gotten the most DMS and
emails about where I'm like oh now I get
you Gary and this works for me too is
when I talk about the reason I don't
have burnout is two things one I
genuinely am not attached to my public
or even private success I don't care if
my parents or my siblings or the world
thinks I'm successful I am very good at
being disciplined to live within my
means I spent all of my 20s all of them
not making up even a hundred thousand
dollars a year which is a lot of money
but like in the way that people think
about money you know I didn't that
didn't happen for me nor did into my
early 30s so I'm very good living within
my means I'm not attached to my success
and then comma
what I do for a living is truly my hobby
truly so like my disciplines are more of
like I don't want like eating habits
working out I only developed that in my
late 30s uh Candor in my personal life
was something I really struggled with
I'm not disciplined saying it like it is
garyvee is great at it which is the
irony of it all the pup my public
Persona went on public in a meeting in
an interview like this I'm very good at
it because I'm talking to the world but
when I'm talking to the 25 people I love
or the 500 employees that I love I
really struggled with it very
undisciplined with Candor but not
burnout and things that nature and so
just I'm sorry to deviate but when you
hear that of somebody who loves to like
like what is that combination of
emotional traits that allows someone
like me to truly not be there like I'm
genuinely not stressed professionally
ever
well that's great I mean I think it it
requires a certain amount of discipline
for me it you know saying no is
something I have to be disciplined about
because I always want to do one more
I'll always want to commit to one more
thing yeah and if I'm not disciplined
about that then inevitably I will burn
out or people around me I I that's
something I have to be conscious of is
like hey if my capacity is a hundred but
people on my team's capacity is 75 I can
only commit to what the team can handle
unless I want to be constantly replacing
those people like or or for all the
operators I couldn't agree more such a
brilliant statement I'm obsessed with
the concept of creating infrastructure
for them to play at their 75 and then I
have to be on an island from my 76 to
100 and not require anyone to be the
facilitator of it hence why I have two
Chiefs of Staff and three full-time
admins that was a big learning step all
my Executives all my operators all my
you know CEOs and CEOs they could I I
could easily manage them with that my
infrastructure of my time that was why I
built out such a large team people laugh
at it but it was actually through
empathy and compassion to the ones to
keep them at their 75.
no it's like you'd think okay I'm I'm
operating at this level I'm having one
person come handle my extra stuff that
should be enough like I should only need
one person to do that it's like no
actually it might be three or four or
five people and you empathy is a great
word there uh and then also
understanding hey I I just noticed I
kept burning through people and it was
expensive and difficult to have to
replace them each time and so I had to
say hey I have to think about what I'm
able to take on what each person is able
to handle or I'm being short-term
disciplined at the expense of long-term
discipline right just because I know
there's a lot of these characters on the
call and I think this will land and I
you know you're a humble dude but I'm
gonna ask you to be for it right about
it
um why do you think you're such a
successful author
because I think a lot of people please I
I treat it like a job I show up and I do
it every day you know right I was
thinking about this when you were
talking about some of these social media
people I think people look at an
influencer and they go oh that's fun you
just wake up and write pictures and
you're gonna do whatever you want and
it's like no I I work at this every
single day I show up I do the work and I
I love it and I can't not do it right
there's there's a bunch of factors but
but I think people they look they look
at something and they see the output and
they assume it's easy and they don't
understand the day-to-dayness of it the
commitment to to wanting to get better
to really thinking about hey here here
is here is me doing it at 50 and then
here's me doing it 100 and if there's a
huge difference between giving all like
your best to something and then just you
know sort of phoning it in I I think
that's right and I think back to where
this is why I'm so passionate about
passion because I think it's a lot
easier to be disciplined like if people
said the five people you love the most
health is dependent on you writing
actually writing every morning
I would like go visit those five people
and give them a kiss and say let's
reminisce because you're going downtown
Charlie Brown because I'm incapable of
writing every day like you know it's
like you know this is I think the
extremities of what comes natural and
easy to me versus what comes so hard to
me and this is that that was a part of
I've forever have been affected by how I
was so atrocious at school I'm just like
I'm fascinated by it because I meet so
many people like I did nothing but I got
C's and I was like why didn't I get C's
and and I think to your point the
influencer thing I'm glad you brought
that up I laughed when people make fun
of them
because I know how hard it is and how
much work is required what's a what's a
common thing that you've seen people
do to start the plot process to become
more disciplined is it try to become
micro disciplined about something small
and then you build on that is it just
rip the Band-Aid off and go at it like
is it a babysitter so for me I got to I
I used a babysitter for working out
changed my life I finally figured out
I'm so disciplined at being accountable
to others I'm in charge of my siblings I
love my parents I love my employees I
love the world oh [ __ ] and literally the
reason I got a full-time trainer was to
not let Mike down that drives me more
than going to the gym actually sure
yeah I mean I think there's there's two
easy ways to tackle discipline one might
be routine and structure in your life
like what time do you wake up what's
your calendar look like stop stop sort
of winging it and I think people figured
out during covid like oh wait now I'm My
Own Boss I actually have to be in charge
I can't just do whatever I want when I
want it to me another really easy place
is what you're talking about with is a
physical practice something where you at
Seneca one of my favorite quotes from
Santa Cruz says we treat the body
rigorously so that it is not disobedient
to the mind and the point is you want to
develop the practice of being in charge
like with the the the practice of oh I'm
tired oh it's hard oh it's difficult oh
it's not going well you want to
cultivate the muscle that that is able
to override that and keep going it's
like when you crank the the knob in the
shower towards cold every time you do
that you are developing a strength over
yourself that I think is transferable to
the rest of your life
I think that's I think that's right
um
what
does someone here's a good one because I
see this through my DMs and emails do
you read your DMs and emails right like
a lot a little like how do you play that
I've had to be disciplined about that
like because I know that I focus best
when I'm not thinking about what other
people think of me and when I'm not
getting random criticism or people
telling me that I'm awesome so I've had
to set up some boundaries like I have a
social media person I also my personal
social media is on my wife's phone so I
can't check it as much as I would
ordinarily check it and so I I do get
feedback I like to get that feedback in
person when I meet like real humans like
on the street or at a talk or something
you feel people you feel people are more
civil and more themselves in that
environment correct
yeah and I just don't want a lot of
unsolicited feedback just direct access
to me at any moment I found that that's
not can do it doesn't work for like me
keeping my own internal compass on point
good for you uh I uh and and this goes
back to like self-awareness I on the
other hand I'm so detached from it even
when people like you're the goat or
you're a scam artist I'm actually
spending all my energy on trying to
understand why one is doing that more so
that it's almost like I don't even like
it's almost like I don't even exist it's
super interesting how I treat it
nonetheless this leads me to this
question because I've seen this a lot
a lot of people
struggle with the restart of discipline
after sustaining discipline and falling
off the horse
help us talk through this
for four years you've been great on your
eating and diet and working out and then
covet happened you lost your way and you
feel like all those years were wasted
and you're kind of getting to this
depression Circle for for you know for
17 months you were disciplined with
containing some of the feelings you had
and you were more civil and somebody
triggered you and you lashed out and now
you're lashing out every like and
there's a million different versions of
this uh here's a big one that I hear a
lot about a lot of people really
struggle with being upset that they're
late to everything like a big one yeah I
get a lot of that like I suck I suck I'm
like you don't suck like like you know
and so that person gets good they
created a system admin calendar alert
systems apps who knows what they do it
for three and a half years oh darn they
got out of that pattern and they're no
longer help us get back once disciplined
lost their way how do I get back on the
discipline train I'm given that you've
looked at this subject matter I'm sure
you got some thoughts on this
yeah look Gill is not a constructive
emotion whipping yourself telling
yourself that you suck it's not helpful
right it it feels self-indulgent it
feels like it's helping but it's not
right uh one of my favorite lines from
The Stokes they say how do you know
you're making progress you're being a
better friend to yourself and you know a
friend doesn't go like Gary you're such
a piece of [ __ ] you're late I hate you
right they go hey uh what's up with you
are you okay do you need something right
like I'm just checking in I'm seeing how
you're doing and and so realizing that
we all fall short we're human beings
it's going to happen
um and then that's the end of that
discussion and then it's about getting
back closer to where you want to be or
who you want to be as opposed to this
downward spiral because because you
slipped up or you fell off like I just
think about it as like there's this kind
of Rhythm this bass line of who I want
to be and sometimes I'm way above it and
sometimes I I fall below it but I just I
know where I want to come back to all
the time and it's like it's like if
you're ever playing music you know the
beat is going and you can come and go
with it but it's always there you just
got to come back to that beat I love
that I love that what uh what did you
learn most
you know this is obviously something
you've been into
aware of thoughtful about research you
associate with it so it's been very
tried and true for you for a long time
you write this book you you have to go a
little deeper thus you must have
stumbled on something what what was that
well one of the things I'm thinking
about in my life that I've taken from it
is that you know discipline is not just
rigidity like you talked about being on
my mind I love it five minutes early or
like I never do this you know that
rigidity is also a form of fragility you
have to be able to be flexible right you
have to be able to adjust especially as
you get you know in the higher levels of
things so like when you see athletes
that have this routine they're like I
always do it this way well what if the
team playing is late because of weather
you know what if what if you're you're
not playing on the home court because
something changed you have to like you
have to be resilient and part of
resilience is flexibility being able to
say I can work with this it does would
it would it would it would it wouldn't
you argue that's the highest level of
discipline
I mean for me for me when I think about
discipline it's that my mental status
with myself when I talk to myself is
always apologetic and understanding of
things out of my control
yes that is my core discipline my core
discipline is I wanted this to be the
case
the plane it snowed Mother Nature said
go [ __ ] yourself I said thank you mother
nature and we got in at 3am it's okay
that I'm not gonna wake up at 6am and
work out because I'm tired and it's okay
and I'll pick it back up tomorrow and
that's that
well and that that actually requires
more discipline I think so get in at
three you normally work out at six you
like working out you get the dopamine
from working out you have a streak going
on your smart watch that you don't want
to break but sleep is important you know
being fresh for the meeting in the
morning or the talk that you're giving
in the morning and and your health is
important and if you force a workout
when you're stiff or you know not
prepared not to you could hurt yourself
and so you have to have the discipline
like for me I it's harder for me not to
work out but I'm not feeling well than
it is for me to force it anyway right
and so it takes discipline to be
flexible actually and say I'm going to
adjust I'm going to sleep in I'm gonna
move this thing in my calendar I'm gonna
do X Y and Z and I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm
gonna adjust I don't control what
happens to go to your point but we
control how we adjust to what happens
how we respond to what happens that's
actually the the essence of stone
philosophy right there you know it's
funny well I got you for five minutes it
like my brain's just racing and where it
wants to go is the rigidness the
rigidness the people in my life who are
obsessed with the world being black and
white
are incredibly unhappy
I breaks your heart it breaks my heart
watching them many are the closest of
the closest to me others are the next
Circle in the next Circle
and all of it traces back to
fear
you know that they they're trying to
protect themselves from an unknown
because it hurts they're scared of you
know and I think you've said something
so powerful that got me going to this
place which is like do not consider
discipline being rigid and it's funny
because it triggered me in a good way
I'm like right like I think my
superpower is is you know you said this
to me on a podcast not judging myself
and I think it speaks to a deep
Obsession of flexibility and non-rigid I
mean I it's actually scary to me how not
rigid I am
and and I think about this you know
great athletes have discovered that hey
pliability flexibility is actually more
important than strength you know if
you're just lifting lifting lifting
first off you're going to hurt yourself
you're going to wear yourself down but
what about when you get tackled what
about you of course you have to reach
for the ball if you're not pliable if
you're not flexible that's when you pull
a muscle and I think there's a metaphor
in there for the rest of us we have to
be able to adjust and bend and go with
the flow of things as opposed to
diluting ourselves so we can be so
strong and rigid that that we've never
been we never break you know life's
gonna
disabuse you of that ocean
I think that's right I you know if
there's anything I want people to leave
with is emotional flexibility as a North
star is just so good like it's it's
probably what I've spent the majority of
my life trying to do through osmosis
around my inner circles professionally
and personally it just it's so darn
clear
well I think about this with routine
right it's one thing that I wake up at
this time I do this this and then what
about when you're on the road right so I
actually think about it routines plural
right I'm just I have different routines
that I do in different ways hey actually
the morning one's not going to work I'm
gonna move into the afternoon it's
important that you have key practices
things that you always try to do but you
have to be able to shuffle them around
adjust because life is constantly
shuffling you around and adjusting you
yeah and the thing that I always worry
about for the people I love and this is
probably an important conversation for
people to listen to is when people
struggle with
things changing that are tiny
what happens when things change when
they're big
yeah like when you lose a loved one
when there is a pandemic when they're
when your country is going through
turmoil or anxiety like you know there's
just like all these things that are
happening in our world today and like
you know the lack of flexibility is
leading people into deeper and deeper
spirals
yeah that doesn't mean you don't have
principles that there aren't codes that
are core to who you are but it's about
the little things that don't matter that
you want to be able to adjust so
precisely as you said in the big things
you don't change this is why I love you
because you touch on things when I make
statements in a similar manner that I do
like you so were able to take that last
sentence and speak to another common
thing that you hear from the
Counterpoint which is you're absolutely
right my principles
are non-bendable the problem is they're
so macro and so like universally based
on things like kindness and love that
you know it's not about like people
being late
yeah like my poor father for example
like
like somebody being late to this like
and actually I'll use a business example
to help people my father growing up we
had this crazy good employee the guy was
getting ten dollars an hour Ryan like he
was a young kid
the kid clearly was like in that I'm
late life you know and he would come in
at 903 and 904 and 906 and 902 and 901
and my dad would like obsess over his
punch card
this kid was disproportionately the most
valuable employee in the company besides
me and he was making ten dollars and
that was when we were very small
business
and I and I just like really struggled
with and my you know with my dad and we
would argue and fight I would cry I was
really 15 16 at this point so I was
really like emotionally charged and
arguing with my dad if it went a certain
way I would cry I'd be like Dad the VA
like like I don't get it like the value
this guy brings and look what he does
and what if he quits and this and that
and like you want to yell at him for
this and I'm like it's a couple of
millions like the principle it's the
principle it's the principle and like
the discipline like and I was like No
it's it's really not and I think the
reason I want to tell that story is an
Ender is I think a lot of people right
now are running families organizations
relationships companies one employee a
virtual employee and they're getting
hung up on something that they think is
an important
principle and they think it's important
because you know I could see somebody
taking this conversation from the wrong
angle and trying to deploy discipline on
their employees instead of disciplining
themselves in the macro right they leave
here and be like oh please
it's important to realize we're talking
about
self-discipline yes right you're not a
drill sergeant yes you don't you don't
you don't control these other
self-discipline the stoics say tolerant
with others strict with yourself correct
and that you can decide that I'm
punctual I'm never late you should be
flexible you should be able to adjust
but the point is you don't get to decide
these rules and then project them onto
other people and and this is the
important part be disappointed or
frustrated or despair what Ryan what is
that what is that called if stoics are
doing it that way what are people that
are doing at the reverse because I'm
very hot on these last four minutes
because I got real feelings about
leadership parenting so what what is
that called do we categorize that like
how is that talked about in slang that's
called being a tyrant you know if you're
trying to control every little thing
that every people other people do you're
trying to monitor their personal
decisions and you know you're you know
yeah and what bothers me the most is
always out of self-interest often
Financial
yes yes
[ __ ]
but but short-term Financial because the
long-term no [ __ ] we want to cultivate
great talent and do what that Talent
needs to be successful and if that's
being two minutes late who cares
retention matters I know that you've
written a book that went crazy viral in
the sports world because I'm always
recruiting and this and that and plus I
think you know Belichick liked it which
really pissed me off and kind of hurt
our friendship but you know I think
about retention all the time
um and I think about it from Sports
quite a bit teams that have that same
core it's very clear and
you see it in golden state and
basketball right now and
um and I believe in it so much in the
workplace and to your point another
tremendous add-on a good cherry on the
end of this once again you added a
tremendous point because it bleeds
retention and you're absolutely right
the financial value is extremely short
term
yeah brother you and I are always on the
same wavelength it really are and like
the one thing that you do that I like so
much is and and maybe because it comes
so natural to me is I like that you're
able to take a sentence and like take it
to the next place you did it two or
three times here and I really noticed it
this time even more in the past so I
admire that because it is a higher
understanding of the thing of the thing
you know and I think
actually I'm really excited I think this
is really going to be valuable for a lot
of people listening even if this isn't
for you about discipline I think if you
really maybe even re-listen to this
podcast
I think the thematics play out in a lot
of Arenas a lot of self traits of this
gray versus black and white
um I really like that strict with
yourself I mean
you know I say it differently and it
drives people around me crazy I always
say I don't have expectations of others
I just don't I I just try to take their
reality and try to make it good
you work with what they give you a
hundred percent I'll give you one more
minute here because I'm enjoying this
too much what did we not touch on in the
bouncing around that we just did that's
core to the book or something you wanted
to say or something I'll bring value to
someone to understand why they want
well look when you're talking about high
forms of discipline I do think that the
highest form of discipline though is
when you are so strict with yourself and
you model these behaviors and it
inspires others to be more disciplined
right so the great leaders make everyone
else on the team more disciplined not by
force not by yelling but by modeling
those traits they don't talk about it
they are about it that's that's what I
think ultimately we want to Aspire to do
as leaders
we'll leave it with that Ryan thank you
so much
you're the best man cheers
[Music]